how do you hide an entire city well
starting in the 1940s the Soviet Union
had not just one city but hundreds of
them
these were cities so secret that they
were kept off of every official map and
had no proper town names but there was
one in particular 25 miles northeast of
Moscow that was truly special closed
military townlet number one didn't look
like much it was some drab concrete
apartment buildings some nondescript
offices hidden way out in the middle of
the woods but it was hidden from the
world for a reason in the 1960s it was
home to one of the Soviet Union's most
closely guarded scientific programs this
drab little town was also known as star
City and it was where the cosmonauts
lived
over a hundred cities and a million
people literally living off the map if
you lived in one of these cities your
town had no name and you as a citizen
were yourself capped out of view in 1960
the Soviet Union ordered the creation of
a brand-new closed city it was the
cosmonaut training center the small team
of cosmonauts moved to Star City and
they only took up one building it was a
tiny operation but slowly it began to
grow over the 1960s they built the best
space program in the world at least for
a while during the 1960's the Soviet
Union invested heavily in its cosmonaut
program and plan extensively for a lunar
landing Star City itself blossomed into
a real town its own post office movie
theater a railway station and a couple
of schools and all of this investment
paid off the Soviet Union not just sent
the first satellite into space but the
first dog the first man the first woman
and did the first spacewalk all of this
was bearing fruit it was bearing space
fruit
by the 1990s the great communist dream
had fallen apart and in 1991 when the
Soviet Union collapsed mirror was in the
sky with an astronaut inside of it but
Kazakhstan where he needed to land was
no longer part of the Soviet Union so he
was left up there for months
well someone figured out what to do with
him and where he could land in 2008
control was finally and officially
handed over from the military fully to
Rus cosmos the Russian version of NASA
and this marked the first sort of true
opening of Star City to the public you
could actually go and visit Star City
for the first time and you can today
they offer tours so well the secrecy of
Star City has faded its aesthetic
remains firmly fixed in the 1960s and
1970s it's got kind of a retro
futuristic shabby-chic thing going on
but don't be fooled by the aesthetic
Star City still contains some of the
best training equipment in the world in
fact with the Space Shuttle retired the
Soyuz rocket designed in the 1960s and
built to last is the only way to get to
space subscribe here and watch more
videos here that astronaut who was left
up in mirror who was launched when it
was the Soviet Union and landed when it
was Russia he runs the whole place now